Studio Ghibli has something for everyone
whether it's a fantastical adventure
drama or romance in celebration of this
vast collection of animated works here
is a ranking of all of Ghibli z'
feature-length films from worst to best
tales from Earthsea follows an exiled
prince and a wandering wizard as they
navigate a fantasy world while some
scenes in the film look absolutely
gorgeous the overall visual quality of
the film lacks consistency the film
still looks like a Studio Ghibli film
but it lacks the sense of life that
characterizes other films from the
famous animation studio in addition the
plot incorporates elements from several
of the Earth's ebooks and suffers as a
result tales from Earthsea feels at once
bloated with plot points and characters
while also starved of depth since
there's not enough time to explore each
concept the sprawling plot and the
shallow character motivations all end up
making tales from Earthsea
the weakest Studio Ghibli film by far my
neighbor's the Yamada's is a comedy in
the style of a Japanese comic strip the
film is a compilation of stories
following members of the Yamada family
and each segment different issues are
explored like disputes between the
married couple and the various
relationships of the family members
though my neighbor's the Yamada's is an
inoffensive and entertaining watch the
film simply pales in comparison to other
Studio Ghibli titles it's definitely not
the most impressive entry in the
studio's long history but my neighbor's
the Yamada's is a cute film with comedic
elements that many viewers are bound to
enjoy from up on poppy Hill follows umi
matsuzaki a high school student in the
port city of Yokohama each morning
outside of the boarding house where she
lives
Bumi raises a series of signal flags in
honor of her father who died during the
Korean War
one day she meets a boy who wrote about
her flags in a student newspaper and the
two said about renovating the building
where the school clubs are supposed to
be held the pair began to fall for each
other as they continue working on the
renovation even after the school board
decides to demolish the building the
setting is perhaps where the film shines
the brightest while the city of Yoko
isn't a fantastical setting for a film
the film nearly makes it seem
fantastical by paying special attention
to the time period the story takes place
in 1963 as the nation gets ready to host
the 1964 Olympic Games and the little
touches throughout the film helped to
ground the story in a specific time in
place from up on poppy Hill isn't a bad
film overall but the film's mundane
setting and somewhat predictable plot we
can the experienced young kid story it's
not a magical story like Saipan yo but
there's a beauty to it that's brought by
the fact that it's animated Porco Rosso
follows a former Italian fighter pilot
who's cursed to look like an
anthropomorphic pig after the first
world war Porco makes it his duty to
hunt down air pirates who use their
planes to wreak havoc on honest people
but when a young pirate shoots his
aircraft down Porco has to make a
dangerous journey to his mechanic so he
can repair his plane Porco Rosso is a
light-hearted action film that goes to
great lengths to show Hayao Miyazaki's
admiration of early aviation there are a
lot of shots of Porco operating is
playing with the use of several levers
sticks and pedals that highlights the
film's attention to detail while the
story is relatively safe the real draw
of this film is the action during the
mid-air dogfights
though not as groundbreaking as other
Studio Ghibli titles Porco Rosso still
has plenty to offer as a film the wind
rises is a fictionalized biography of
Jiro horikoshi a renowned Japanese
airplane designer from the early 20th
century the film follows judo as he
falls in love with his terminally ill
wife and finds fulfillment in designing
planes however throughout the film judo
worries about the ethics surrounding his
invention since he primarily develops
them for the Japanese military the wind
rises centers on a prominent historical
figure who many Americans have likely
never heard of while that could have
been interesting on its own the film
unfortunately suffers from pacing
problems that make the wind rises' feel
dragged out still for history buffs and
fans of aviation the wind rises is
likely to soar to the top of your
favorite movie lists
airplanes on beautiful dreams engineers
turn dreams into reality
in pom Poko construction on the
outskirts of Tokyo has led to the
surrounding forests becoming drained of
its natural resources as the threat of
deforestation looms magical creatures
known as tanuki take desperate measures
they begin staging elaborate hauntings
to scare humans attracting media
attention and even relying on
eco-terrorism to stall construction pom
Poko is an environmentally conscious
film that aims to highlight the plight
of animals rapidly losing their lands to
suburban development despite some
heavy-handed themes and awkward pacing
the film has plenty of fun expressive
animation that still makes pom Poko and
engaging watch similar to the Little
Mermaid Ponyo is a cute love story about
a fish girl named Ponyo who befriends
Sasuke
a human boy when she strays away from
home Ponyo is a genuinely beautiful film
with amazingly creative designs both in
terms of world building and characters
however it suffers from slow pacing in
an overly simple story that being said
O'Neil isn't aiming for death the film
wants to take viewers on a fantastical
visual journey under the sea and in that
respect it excels though it isn't
perfect
Ponyo is more than worth watching for
the gorgeous animation and cute childish
romance between Sasuke and Ponyo after
Haru Yoshioka saves the life of a cat
crossing the street her life takes a
turn for the weird when the cat turns
out to be the Prince of cat Kingdom and
asks for her hand in marriage with a
fantastical premise the Cat Returns is a
cute fantasy adventure that's plenty of
fun to watch still the film lacks the
grand scope that has come to be expected
from Studio Ghibli titles compared to
the visual masterpiece of spirited away
which was released during the same year
as the cat returns the latter film is
both lighter and tone and a bit less
daring in terms of animation still the
film is definitely enjoyable on its own
merits and is an overall solid flick for
animation fans and cat lovers alike
[Music]
when Marnie was there follows Anna a
young girl sent to live with her foster
parents family in Hokkaido due to her
poor health Anna is lonely and depressed
until she needs a strangely familiar
girl named Marnie a mysterious blonde
girl living in a dilapidated old house
in the marshes the true strength of when
Marnie was there lies largely in it's
interesting female leads anna has
trouble connecting with others and
considers herself an outlier in her
society given this the relationship that
develops between Anna and Marnie is
incredibly sincere as it develops
throughout giving Anna someone that she
can finally relate to in the end the
great connection shared by the two leads
mystery surrounding Marnie's character
and the film's impressive animation all
come together to create a satisfying and
relatable film in my dreams I saw a girl
just like you dreams Howl's Moving
Castle follows Sophie a hat maker who is
cursed to look like an old woman by a
witch while travelling to find a way to
break the witch's spell sophie meets an
enchanted scarecrow and seeks out howl
a wizard who lives in a magical Moving
Castle Miyazaki's works are always
filled with commentaries on how humans
interact with nature staying true to the
creator's passion for taking care of the
environment
however Howl's Moving Castle also
focuses on how humans interact and bond
with each other in conveying this theme
Howl's Moving Castle considers
complicated topics such as war loyalty
to nations and coming to terms with
aging the unique variety of themes
combines with the now standard fare of
breathtaking animation fun characters
and plenty of humor all together it
makes Howl's Moving Castle one of the
most inventive Studio Ghibli films
around the princess of the valley of the
wind is Nausicaa an adventurous young
woman who wants her people to coexist
with the neighboring toxic jungle and
its animal and insect inhabitants
however the peace of the valley is put
at risk when a plane from a neighboring
country crashes in the valley the planes
cargo harbors the embryo of a giant
warrior an enormous and dangerous insect
that will be used to destroy the toxic
jungle everything falls to Nausicaa to
find a way to restore peace to both
lands and find harmony between nature
and humans Nausicaa of the valley of the
wind is one of Hayao Miyazaki's most
environmentally conscious features and
one that's clearly close to his heart
the film was created before Studio
Ghibli existence but the success of
Nausicaa is what led to the studio's
creation without Nausicaa it is fair to
assume we may not have gotten many of
the Studio Ghibli titles that we have
today even beyond its place in the
studio's history Nausicaa is
breathtakingly original with all of the
unique character designs and luscious
animation that you would expect in
whisper of the heart Shizuka is a
student about to take her high school
entrance exams she soon meets Seiji a
talented musician who dreams of becoming
a master violin maker
Seiji leaves for Italy to follow his
dreams while Shizuka decides to devote
herself to writing while other Studio
Ghibli films may stand out for their
lush environments or their tense action
scenes whisper of the hearts strength is
the emotional journey that she's if he
goes on throughout the film whisper of
the heart is impressive and how it
tackles the creative process and the
struggles of balancing creative
endeavors with more traditional pursuits
the film is relatable and down-to-earth
making whisper of the heart one of the
more uniquely mundane films from the
studio initially released in 1993 ocean
waves is a bit different from other
Studio Ghibli titles in that it was
originally produced for television
additionally it's the first Ghibli film
not to feature Hayao Miyazaki or 'south
takahasi as director ocean waves tells
the story of a love triangle between
Taku his best friend Yutaka and the new
exchange students Rika clue after Taku
joins Rika crew for an unexpected trip
to Tokyo tensions rise and rumors begin
to develop about Rika ku and tacos
relationship as a result Rika qu Taku
Yutaka must confront the change in
dynamics in the nature of their
relationships with one another for
teenage love story the overall likable
ocean waves is generally pretty good
though it may not be as strong as
similar Studio Ghibli films it's a solid
engaging drama after moving closer to
their hospital bound mother sisters
Satsuki and may discover a host of
magical beings living in their new town
guided by friendly dust creatures Mae
meets Totoro a giant cat-like animal
that lives in a hollow by the girls
house eventually Totoro also reveals
himself to Satsuki and the sisters are
introduced to the whimsical life shared
by Totoro and his fantastical friends
though the film is mostly filled with
cute critters and upbeat interactions
between Satsuki and her younger sister
it also has its fair share of tension My
Neighbor Totoro is wildly fun to watch
and instills a sense of childlike wonder
that few other films can achieve
considering castle on the sky was the
first film to be produced under the name
Studio Ghibli in 1986 it stands the test
of time incredibly well the story begins
with shita a young orphan pursued by
space pirates and government officials
for her mysterious necklace cheetah is
found and sheltered by another orphan
named posi the two go on a journey to
uncover the secrets of sheeta's necklace
and its airborne
origin castle in the sky does a good job
of setting the tone for future Studio
Ghibli films in that it has a sweeping
soundtrack a mystical world filled with
advanced technology and themes
surrounding humans in their relationship
to nature while better Ghibli films
would come later castle on the sky
remains a standout in the studio's
history The Secret World of Arrietty
film follows a family of borrowers tiny
people who scavenge or borrow from the
houses of ordinary humans the family's
safety is threatened when the young boy
of the house
Schull sees Arrietty while she and her
father are borrowing in his room late
one night while Studio Ghibli films are
renowned for their ability to create
fantastical worlds The Secret World of
Arrietty engenders that same sense of
wonder scope and event
sure within its utterly normal setting
in addition to beautiful animation and
excellent art design the film has a
lovely soundtrack that helps build on
the sweet overall tone with a blend of
fantastic music and visuals The Secret
World of Arrietty is a beautiful tale of
blossom and friendship that perfectly
balances between a calm slice of life
narrative and a fun adventure story I am
very proud of him a lesser borrower
would have panicked and run away in
Princess Mononoke Prince ashitaka finds
himself poisoned after a demon attacks
his village in search of a cure ashitaka
goes to iron town where the people cut
down the forest to fuel their
manufacturing-based society this
disturbance of nature upsets the spirits
of the forest who go to war with the
people of iron town as the war threatens
to wipe out both the nature spirits and
the humans ashitaka and Sun a human
raised by spirits must work together to
achieve some form of peace one of
Jubilees most well known pictures
Princess Mononoke does an excellent job
of blending an action-packed adventure
with a nuanced environmental message
Kiki's Delivery Service follows a young
witch named Kiki as she leaves her home
and begins her training as a witch in a
new town supported by her talking black
cat Gigi she flies to a seaside town
where she's hosted by a friendly Baker
and her husband quickly Kiki finds her
footing as a delivery girl and captures
the attention of a boy named tumble with
clamors for her attention Kiki's
Delivery Service is a magical tale with
beautiful animation that makes the
film's world feel warm and idyllic all
of the characters are expressive and
relatable especially Kiki who struggles
to fit into her new town and discover
her unique talents starting as
overconfident and slowly becoming
isolated and unsure Kiki is a
brilliantly fleshed out character that
encourages viewers to overcome obstacles
and fly high only yesterday strays away
from Studio Ghibli conventions by
targeting older viewers as opposed to
teens and children's the film explores
the life of taiko Okajima an unmarried
woman who takes a trip outside of
Tokio to the rural countryside outside
the city taiko begins to feel nostalgia
for her childhood and questions her life
choices because of only yesterday's
focus on an adult protagonist and her
growing disillusionment with her life
the film offers a mature and reflective
exploration of aging unlike many other
Ghibli titles there's no magical
adventures instead the story of only
yesterday offers a slice of life
experience that is grounded in reality
the film does an excellent job of
fleshing out Tycho's memories and allows
her to come to terms with who she is and
what she wants out of life only
yesterday has a unique charm and Relays
a beautiful story of growth reflection
and self-discovery sceneries come about
by lucky accident as people have
struggled with nature to get what they
needed to survive with a distinct
watercolor aesthetic the tale of
Princess Kaguya is a beautifully
animated movie based on a beloved
Japanese folktale in the film a bamboo
cutter finds a girl inside a bamboo
shoot' whom he names Kaguya realizing
that the girl is divine
he moves Kaguya to a mansion in the
capital where she is trained to become a
noble lady
despite Caguas growing discomfort the
tale of the princess kaguya is without a
doubt one of Studio Ghibli s most
visually unique works with distinct
animation and style the film is an
incredible experience from start to
finish
arguably the most well known of the
Studio Ghibli films spirited away
follows Chiquito as she works to save
her parents who unknowingly trespassed
into the world of spirits as punishment
for stealing food chiquitos parents are
transformed into pigs by the powerful
witch yubaba
while working at a bathhouse to save her
family she hid old learns determination
how to assert herself and the value of
compassion spirited away is absolutely
gorgeous with masterful animation and
heartfelt character designs fantastic
visuals accompanied by the film's
colorful cast of creative lovable
characters solidify spirited away as one
of the most beloved animated films of
all time
taking place in Japan during World War
two grave of the fireflies follow SATA
and Setsuko siblings who managed to
survive a fire bombing that destroys
their home thrust into the role of a
parent SATA must find a way to feed
himself and his sister in the midst of
rapidly shrinking supplies grave of the
fireflies is unique in that it reveals
the main characters deaths at the
beginning of the film the remainder of
the runtime is told through a flashback
that contextualizes safe as death and
hardships he was forced to endure
ultimately the film is a grim and
heartbreaking experience that bears far
more weight than any other Studio Ghibli
movie in the end Seita and Setsuko are
innocent children whose lives are
destroyed by a war they had no say in in
a post-war society
no one can provide for these children
forcing SATA into an adult role he is
largely unprepared to handle while grave
of the fireflies may prove too difficult
for some viewers to endure the film's
message about war and tragedy is
powerful check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belts so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]